[Music]
that's with that kid you just showed up
out of nowhere
where's your parents my kid come on do
you live with me I'm the new doctor for
the plantation if any of you are sick or
get hurt just see Joe he'll come get
[Music]
you know enjoy you seemed pretty smitten
with the big man's pretty daughter
[Music]
meet your help I got another one like
this
[Music]
[Applause]
miss Grace has her triangle let's guys
let's just show them that you're a
qualified assistant
without your wrist I'm gonna check your
pulse faster than normal it's all the
way okay
they're bringing in another doctor this
is dr. Reyes he's here to offer us
second opinion aren't you a true beauty
morning mr. Daniels taka asked me to
come by and drop off that web be
necessary this place is now under the
care of a proper decision when the doc
may take care of Orientals never labels
do you have a crush on the Danielson's
daughter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have been trying to adopt this kid I
believe this young man has the baby's
position perhaps you'd like to be on a
winning team the distinguished doctor
has taken that interesting new idea a
miracle your only daughter I wouldn't
give up you're meant to be in it grace
[Music]
it's gotta be a way we can shorten the
distance between the mound and the ocean
state is
you
you